je viens au monde les royaumes de fleuve
sénégal se battent entre eux
pour voir qui fournira le plus
d'esclaves au blanc mannarini nanani
aujourd'hui par les esclavages n'ont
parlé du cpm est si complexe six multi
des vieilles histoires
sipa médias l'histoire de notre histoire
notre histoire
personne ne meurt pas quand il ya
quelqu'un
[Musique]
j'ai eu un fils regarde le cynisme ni à
ma wii noire à la théorie et à
comprendre noire des à
l'hôpital et des malades et de la mine à
nos minots nominal mon appart est
appliquée
[Musique]
m
je suis l'un s'être de ce canton vol en
france et dans l'enfant suit toujours ma
travers tous ceux qui croient qu'ils se
barrent veille c'est merveilleux je
voulais que mon histoire à vous dans
l'aisne ce que vous voudrez bien j'étais
presque jetés en ligne un malinois ni
mauvaises mains très sympa comme 11
heures
[Musique]